like you have that kind of time for bob
lazar yes
yes
but maybe not for donald trump no that's
different because bob lazar
what what you know what he's talking
about like i wanted to know with the
babazar thing i wanted to know first i
want to be around him and see if i could
smell [ __ ] did you like did okay no
i didn't man that was what's weird about
it not only did i not smell [ __ ] i
went over all of his interviews i went
he hasn't done a lot but he's done
enough
and he's done them over the course of
30 plus years and
it's alarming how consistent his story
is which is really weird when you think
about you're talking about back
engineering alien crafts and working on
a
you know a top secret government test
site that's carved into the side of a
mountain and to camouflage it from
satellites
it's a it's such a wacky story
but the guy really did work at los
alamos labs he really is a propulsions
expert he really is a scientist um
did he really work on back engineering
ufos i don't know but the way he
described their motion is exactly like
what's been observed by uh some of these
pilots that have these videos that
they've captured and i just love that
like nasa i've been hearing from a bunch
of folks who they're legitimately
like funding research and
there's people really
taking this seriously of um ufo
sightings investigating them yeah like
adding more and more sensors to collect
data from just observing
higher definitions it's it's cool to
finally see that and he was one of the
early people whether he's full of [ __ ]
or not that kind of
forced people to start taking this kind
of
these topics seriously or at least
force people to have conversations about
them and maybe attempt to debunk them
because it seems so preposterous but
then get sucked down the rabbit hole and
start going hmm maybe we'll [ __ ] it's
the thing is like the fermi paradox like
where are they right
and when you take into account just the
sheer raw numbers the vast majority of
people objectively assume that there is
life out there
the vast majority well if if you really
take into account what we understand
about the universe itself what we
understand about the concept of of
infinity and the way neil degrasse tyson
has explained it to me is that
not only
are there life forms out there but
there's you you are out there infinity
is so large that lex friedman exists and
doesn't just exist but exists an
infinite number of times like the amount
of interactions that cells and molecules
the same exact interactions that have
happened here on earth have happened in
the exact same order an infinite number
of times in the cosmos
you